here's what would happen if we sunk our
trash in the Mariana Trench
the Mariana Trench at its deepest point
is 11 kilometers below sea level now
humans produce 2 billion tons of waste
every year but the trench is so vast it
could hold as much as 970
000 billion tons of trash we'd use
garbage pipes capable of withstanding
the immense pressure at these depths to
transport our waste to the bottom out of
sight out of mind right well it would
still cause pollution waste is filled
with dangerous Metals chemicals and
microplastics that leak out into its
surroundings these chemicals and
microplastics would then be passed on to
us humans through the fish we eat the
water we drink and even the air we
breathe so instead let's focus on
creating less waste because